[Music]
in personal growth news mm-hmm I always
want to grow my knees why are you saying
I don't know he forgot he left the
personality personal growth news
you've really left the cake in those
personal girls miss go no idea I'm just
completely thrown thrown out there
submitted by it love from Vegas oh I
love you to Vegas Oh fun I've ever had
and you always go but you don't have
that much fun huh it's always the people
never the place but then sometimes I
could go to Vegas alone maybe and have a
blast too
I don't know if I do that yeah
especially if you're single that's
almost like degenerate stuff like
drinking alone yeah and it's gonna make
it so like wow I would to play poker in
Vegas with my friends and I probably
pulled like a 24-hour session just by
myself at the same table yeah it'll suck
you in you don't know what time did you
get food delivered there well you can
just eat hell yeah as best you can eat
there take a the bathrooms right there
yeah it's a massage oh yeah you could
play in there like working on you that's
you poker players are the original
gamers yeah yeah true this is the age
when your self-esteem is the highest
tell me more is it I bet you it's like
75 oh you just by that time you know who
the [ __ ] you are you don't give a [ __ ]
then all the naked dudes in the locker
room that don't give a damn are always
like seniors dick dangling all that [ __ ]
they don't give up oh yeah because you
don't have to give a [ __ ] about what you
look like yeah you know your school give
up a lot and scream at a tree and no one
would give a fun do whatever the [ __ ] I
want they're about to die they say it as
it is
mm-hmm yeah so the age is 60 they're
young I think I see AIDS when your
self-esteem is the highest that's 60
rows at nudist beaches why you gotta
wait so long
I feel like it takes that much time
though to just be okay because also it's
at that age to where you start thinking
about death because right now like death
isn't around the corner for us we're not
thinking about it
we're like individual because 65 yes so
then it's like I think there goes you go
two ways it's like one you either get us
obsessed with it or the other way you're
just like I'll give up but imma just say
I don't you know what I'm gonna just
live free now yeah I'll be so cocky at
60 I'm just be like I got 60 years worth
of information in my brain everyone's
[ __ ] compared to me I'm like the
biggest hard drive around let's see what
her two-year-old thing to say bro huh
that's super 30 year old thing to say a
super 30 oh yeah let's just say that you
it's it's super that's a super because
the six year olds not being a dick to
everybody else see he's already beyond
that he's like a term or something
yeah I see they don't think that way at
sixty I think they're so wise they're
accepting and you can't even see now
there's some 60 rows are dicks and
that's probably me yeah so let's talk
about self-esteem here so there's talk
about it first it starts so self esteem
begins to rise between the ages of four
and eleven as children are developing it
starts to what right yeah and then like
they started gain some sort of self or
some sort of sense of independence then
the levels seem to plateau but not
decline puberty is a [ __ ] as the
teenagers begin from ages 11 to 15
surprisingly so then they're also saying
that people at lowest no self esteem
appears to hold a steady until mid
adolescence after that there's low like
self esteem seems to increase
substantially until the age 30
then more gradually throughout middle
adulthood before peaking at around age
60 and remaining stable until age 70
after that period so it never drops it
just
kind of goes like this beauty this is
when it starts dropping so then um
they're saying that people will start
having a decline of self-esteem around
70
which makes sense and I'll tell you why
cuz I got big-ass ears and they're
self-conscious of it way more
significant around the age 90 so they're
saying that old age frequently involves
loss of social roles because think about
it most people retire at around 70 so
your sense of purpose who you are your
friends are dying
your friends are yeah body's not working
someone has to yeah someone you just
self-control is like Edelen you know you
can't do it your virtual yourself you're
you feel like a burden to you you're
like a smart ass baby and no one thinks
you're cute
just kill me at 70 yeah no but that's
just most people though right because
[ __ ] Stanley is like a hundred and
fifty or some [ __ ] looks like he's still
into seventies or some [ __ ] you know I
mean like it all did thank her because
he is a somebody five yeah yeah yeah
like so this is for most people like if
you are somebody like Stanley yeah
people know you people want to lie to
you Benny moment how did she pass away
didn't she know don't you [ __ ] dare
say that Jesus Christ Betty if you're a
she's may be sick yeah damn she looks
great it's wonderful yeah and I think
that [ __ ] just keeps you going and
genetics of course but yeah that's what
old people they still want to keep
working when they don't have to yeah
yeah they'll do something anyway that's
the purpose they want to feel like
they're self-sufficient they don't want
to be anyone's burden my mom's still
trying to take care of me and [ __ ] it's
ridiculous like what does she do like
every time we see each other like she
wants to pay for things she wants to
like be my mom and like kind of like
baby me you know that mean like get me
things and whatever like I'll just be
like oh man I'm kind of thirsty
do you find it no a hundred percent i I
miss it too yeah my mom tries to pay for
the bill I'm like [ __ ] we give you
allowance this is my money I still want
to pay for it makes me feel good on my
fine I turn into a [ __ ] eight-year-old
when I go visit my dad I yell at my mom
like feed me or else money call CPS Oh
like literally yelling mom hungry lanes
feed marijuana call CPS on you dare you
not feed me like I turn into a [ __ ]
idiot when I'm around my parents it's
great yeah but another reason why
they're saying that self esteem Peaks
around age 60 is because at that point
you know you've already had an
established life like you're establish
career you're already helping your
children become responsible adults like
you're just like you know that peak
you're civil or your social roles and
that just it's more self fulfilling that
makes sense I think make sense they
typically people make the most money
around their 50s and 60s like that's you
got [ __ ] lined up yeah you're like at
the peak of your careers I mean if you
did life right you know you mean like
you're at higher positions if you think
about like the Executive Board like
these are guys in there like 60s yeah
so that's when they're like making the
most and they're on top of the world and
they're actually the rulers of the
planet I wonder how different it was
through different times
cuz that's super modern time that you're
60 your kids 30 or 40 and they have kids
and you're like building that family or
whatever but like that's probably
different 300 years ago maybe like your
jobs like you said like I undertook the
most amount of money there but like
you're pretty useless probably like 50
back in the day like you're not mowing
the lawns and [ __ ] barmen yeah you're
not farming mm-hmm I actually just went
on a tour Salem witch tour beside the
point but there the height thing is
wrong like people weren't that much
shorter that and they didn't die that
much quicker either Wow
yeah well there's like people in the
1600s still lived 80 yeah the deaths
terrific is basically when you take a
whole population and then you make a
median a dam or babies die that's why
there were so many there's so much
mortality in adolescence yeah so then
like oh there's something and you crunch
that number down that's what happened if
you live like past babyhood and like
past like some buds or something you're
still making it 60 70 80
yeah but then when antibiotics came
around that's when we just started
surviving much longer more people starts
and then fossil feel like an in oil that
that should blew up are people like from
1 billion to like seven billion colder
days looks so bad before like I can't
imagine living in the the what is it
Renaissance like like 1600s 1500s
everyone's probably dying around you
just writing poetry right
era the Dark Ages sake this is what I'm
thinking about yeah dark it yeah but
then right before that you don't mean
the [ __ ] Roman Empire was pretty
sweet
that sounds nice a little bit of wine a
little bit of party if you were rich
gladiator what do you think I would have
been man you know our peasants you were
fun no matter how rich you were you're
probably still drunk no no I'm just
sipping wine watching gladiator they
paint all the time in Rome yeah now they
invented they invented aqueducts and
[ __ ] I'm sure they had soap I need to
use olive oil the Egyptians had milk
baths Egyptians are next level though I
guess cereal like a human cereal human
cereal in Serie A what huh no point your
skin flakes yeah yeah I'm milks prior
moisturiser a little bit of fat yeah but
everyone ate like cleaner food too like
so they probably didn't stink as bad a
Mediterranean diet yeah a little bit of
fish that's the boss and if everybody's
staying together yeah Sam I like the
green olives same I like any old policy
it's called the castilla-la no olive or
some [ __ ] like that it's the green one
not the black one we are all very hungry
if you can I was surprised that the
self-esteem didn't drop during junior
high please well not maybe Oh for some
but then I think a lot of people in
their teenage years they think that they
know everything
well how do you even rank self-esteem if
you ask me one out of ten like if I'm
super self-conscious I'll probably like
me I'm a 9 you're not a 9 shop yeah what
are you gonna say yeah I do remember a
point in time where I felt like like had
the lowest confidence yeah positive like
fifth sixth graders me - it was like
later junior like eighth grade - like
high school as a freshman year prior
yeah freshman are you come in and you're
like the smallest youngest kid or a
[ __ ] dweeb you don't really look like
an adult and you see what seniors look
like and seniors look like this should
be in college or some [ __ ] and they're
just like man I'm like the the [ __ ]
bottom of the totem pole here I'm dumb
and I'm young and I'm
and I'm like I feel like self-esteem
comes like in and out you know what I
mean like it did you just go through
waves of it just like being sick or
depression or whatever like it goes high
and low and high and low yeah I go to
ways even though yeah
like sometimes you just look in the
mirror and you feel like a little [ __ ]
today and you can't do nothing right and
then sometimes you look at you're like
man what the hell you know yeah how do
you get like that yeah yeah yeah I think
it's a it's really rare that people have
prolonged high or low self-esteem
because if you look at the spectrum of
like what is extreme self-esteem then it
ends up being like too high to you to
the point where your delusion again når
sadness yeah and you're weird yeah yeah
or like if it's too low then you're just
like [ __ ] manic depressed or whatever
so I think if people are just always
shifting
[Music]
[Music]